[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning health
officials are very worried about another
new coronavirus wave and they're asking
states
do not lift your restrictions so fast
coveted cases are rising in at least 27
different states plus
washington d.c the number of cases in
the entire u.s is up
13 in the last week meg oliver is in
hackensack new jersey outside of a
hospital
that's seen an increase in patients
there meg this is not good what are you
hearing from the front line workers
gail good morning hospitals like the one
behind me say they're seeing more and
more covert patients
ages 18 to 50. that's because as of
yesterday 50 percent of americans over
65
are fully vaccinated as more contagious
variants continue to spread
younger americans are feeling the brunt
of this latest surge
it's been two weeks since louis
carleglio checked into a connecticut
hospital with coveted symptoms
the 32 year old came home tuesday with
an oxygen tank and iv
marks on his arm scars from a coveted
battle that nearly spiraled out of
control
how bad did it get it began with a fever
that i had for about nine days
and it refused to break at one point i
was on
40 liters of air with 60 oxygen
which unbeknownst to me was eerily close
to the max that you can get
for for high flow air the doctor
kind of later on told me that i wasn't
basically
going to be close to intubation
how did it feel leaving the hospital oh
felt great
it was a beautiful day out today so i
got to breathe in some fresh air
finally as cases rise across the state
hospitals are seeing more patients like
carleglio
according to yale's chief clinical
officer dr tom balsazak
we've seen about a 70 reduction in those
over the age of 55
being admitted to the hospital but
what's that means is we're seeing a lot
more
30 and 40 year olds coming in just last
week we intubated a 21 year old
that's really unheard of for us and how
alarming is that well it's pretty
concerning
i think the message is nobody is
completely safe unless you're vaccinated
just 20 percent of adults over 18 are
fully vaccinated
despite that lack of broad protection
states are relaxing rules on masks and
gatherings
giving more contagious variants
opportunities to spread
says dr ashish jaw our best estimate
right now is probably
50 to 70 percent of all infections in
america
are from b117 that variant from the uk
the
issue is unvaccinated people getting
together and given the variance it's
still pretty risky
and i would avoid it everybody who wants
a vaccine will have had one
and certainly by the time we get into
the summer so my key advice is
hold on tight a little bit longer we're
not talking about months we're talking
about a few more weeks
and carleglio is urging his peers not to
wait if they're eligible for the vaccine
before this happened i wasn't
necessarily rushing to get vaccinated
because i always thought you know i'm in
a group
that's 99.8 percent sure that they're
i'm not going to die from it
my lung capacity is not exactly back so
getting up and walking around for me is
equivalent to like going to the gym
so i need to take it slow
really glad to see him back home now the
recent uptick in the number of cases is
happening mostly in the midwest
and the northeast dr zhao says that's
likely due to the weather it's still
relatively cool here
people are gathering indoors and that's
where the virus spreads more easily
tony wow meg a 32 year old young man
with oxygen a 21 year old intubated it's
a reminder that this virus is not done
with us
meg thank you very much and so important
to tell these stories too because
they say that the vaccine hesitancy is
going down but there still is a lot
out there i always say just look at the
science do the research you're so close
you're still on the fence about it
and we are so close tony we're so close